ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends jack ted
sam and phil meet up for dinner after
they're done jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when phil sends his share to jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then ted
and sam send their respective shares to
jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transaction cites
some issues at the bank that's when jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like litecoin ethereum
c cash and so on one reigns supreme
bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have bill ted and
sam send jack two bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume phil ted and sam
have three bitcoins in reserve while
jack has five first phil sends two
bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block this record also
holds the number of bitcoins each of the
friends own so after phil's transaction
jack has seven bitcoins while phil has
one following this sam and ted send two
bitcoins to jack a new block is created
for each of these transactions
these blocks hold the transaction
details as well as how many bitcoins sam
ted and jack have in reserve these
blocks are linked to each other as each
of them takes reference from the
previous one for the number of bitcoins
each brand owns this chain of records or
blocks is called a ledger and this
ledger is shared among all the friends
which acts as a public distributed
ledger this forms the basis of
blockchain so what happens when phil has
only one bitcoin left and he tries to
send two more bitcoins to jack the
transaction will not go through this is
because all his friends have copies of
the ledger and it's clear that phil has
only one bitcoin left his friends will
flag this transaction as invalid a
hacker will not be able to alter the
data in the blockchain because each user
has a copy of the ledger the data within
the blocks are encrypted by complex
algorithms all of this is made possible
with the help of blockchain technology
blockchain can be described as a
collection of records linked with each
other strongly resistant to alteration
and protected using cryptography
now let's have a closer look at the
bitcoin transaction between jack and
phil and find out how it works every
user in the bitcoin network has two keys
a public key and a private key the
public key is an address that everyone
in the network knows of like an email
address of a user the private key is a
unique address that only the user has
knowledge of something like a password
first phil passes the number of bitcoins
he wants to send to jack along with his
and jack's unique wallet address through
a hashing algorithm all of this is part
of the transaction details these details
are encrypted using encryption
algorithms and using phil's unique
private key this is done to digitally
sign the transaction and to indicate
that the transactions came from phil
this output is now transmitted across
the world using jack's public key with
this the message or transaction can be
decrypted only by jack's private key
which only jack has knowledge of
different cryptocurrencies use different
hashing algorithms while bitcoin uses
the sha-256
algorithm ethereum which is also a
famous cryptocurrency uses one known as
ethash
this transaction and several other
similar ones are taking place all around
the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem the miner
who solves this first adds the block to
the blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining
with this phil and jack's wallets are
updated just like every person in the
network who has completed a transaction
now that you know about blockchain and
its important concepts time for a small
quiz what is the concept of blockchain
that ensures data cannot be altered by
any of the users within the network a
public distributed ledger b
proof of work
c proof of stake d
hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below let's have a look at how
walmart uses blockchain to provide its
customers with better service walmart
was facing problems in delivering
quality products to its customers they
were facing a high return rate and large
amounts of refunds due to their products
bad quality they were unable to
determine the point of failure in the
supply chain which started from farm to
storage to transportation to processing
all the way to the customer then walmart
adopted blockchain technology with
blockchain the quality of the goods at
each step was permanently inscribed
within a block for example when a
customer flags a product has damaged it
can be correctly identified where the
product got damaged in the entire supply
chain thus helping walmart to identify
the problem areas and fixing them and
this is just one of several ways
blockchain is used in real life
applications can you think of any others
let us know in the comments down below
meet frank and daniel
one day they decide to go for a trip to
venice they made a budget list for all
their expenses like residence flight etc
they thought of making their bookings
online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day
while making their respective flight
bookings daniel's transaction failed and
he missed the offer going on
on the other hand frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three lucky draw winners
daniel was surprised and asked frank how
he could make the transaction when
daniel himself could not to which his
response was it's simple i used bitcoin
a type of cryptocurrency
daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 by
satoshi nakamoto
daniel felt that it sounds similar to
other online payment options he asked
what makes it so different
frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference
which means it is not issued and
controlled by any government or central
authority unlike other payment systems
that banks or governments are handling
and that's why a cryptocurrency
transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit for his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank
but on the other hand cryptocurrency
charges almost no or very low
transaction cost there is no limit for
making transactions in fact you have 24
7 access to your money there is no extra
delay or extra charges on making
international transactions
and the best part is that anybody can
use cryptocurrency without the hassles
of paperwork
all you need to do is create an account
on any digital wallet of cryptocurrency
this is what makes cryptocurrency
different from other online payment
options daniel was impressed by
cryptocurrency but he wondered how it
works without the control of an external
authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system
then it is verified and validated by
every node to proceed with the process
of making the transactions
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives
now daniel was completely aware of the
whole technology and concept behind
cryptocurrency and was influenced by
frank to adopt cryptocurrency in his
daily lifestyle too
he did that by booking his ticket but
sadly no discount
like daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide
due to this increasing popularity new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward and investing in
cryptocurrency every day
in 2018 malta an island located in the
mediterranean sea south of italy was
titled blockchain island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
ok x have already begun to take
advantage of malta's financial
incentives and have moved their
headquarters to the blockchain island
so here is a question for you
which hashing algorithm does
cryptocurrency use
a
script
b
ethash
c sha 256 d
none of the above please give it a
thought and drop your answers in the
comments section below
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade spend
and borrow money around the world and
nobody can stop them
people like bill gates co-founder of
microsoft corporation and elon musk ceo
of tesla support cryptocurrency as it is
much better and secure than physical
money and also holds a great future for
the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as a bane to the
world's economy like warren buffett ceo
of berkshire hathaway and ajay benga ceo
of global mastercard feel that
cryptocurrency is a platform of criminal
activities and will destroy the world's
economy
well one thing is clear that this
conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's a reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here